Is Zack Snyder's Justice League a hit?
It seems like it, based on the anecdotal
evidence of buzz and conversation around HBO
Max's streaming-exclusive director's cut of
the DC Comics superhero epic. But since streaming
services generally don't release detailed viewer
data — and when they do say how many people
watched something, there's no reliable way to
check it. People who want to quantify the success
of a piece of streaming entertainment have a
harder time doing it. When trying to measure
the popularity of a streaming movie or show,
there are no easy numbers like box-office
grosses for theatrical releases or Nielsen
ratings for broadcast TV shows. The only
ways to try to quantify it require muddled
estimates of ambiguous metrics that don't
provide anything close to a complete picture.
We will probably never know for sure how
many people watched Ben Affleck's Batman
finally meet Jared Leto's Joker, and
all the hours leading up to that moment.
That being said, the grain-of-salt numbers we do
have should be very exciting for anyone invested
in the success of the Snyder Cut. Bloomberg
reports that downloads of the HBO Max mobile
app increased 64% for the week ending March 28th
over the previous week, according to app data
analysis service Apptopia. 1.48 million people
downloaded the app — though as Forbes notes,
that number isn't necessarily "new subscribers,"
as it may include users who already had access
to HBO Max, but hadn't yet activated the
mobile app. Bloomberg also reports an 8.9%
increase in users opening the app,
a total of 119.1 million launches.
Those numbers sound big, but
let's put them in context.
They are indeed good numbers — especially
compared to HBO Max's competitors.
For the same week, Bloomberg reports
69.7 million app sessions for Disney+,
an increase of 0.4% from the previous week,
and a 4% increase in mobile app downloads.
Disney's streaming service already has over 100
million subscribers, according to The Verge,
while HBO Max is projected to have between
67 and 70 million subscribers by the end of
the year. So HBO Max's app outperformed
Disney+ the same week Disney+ premiered
a new Marvel limited series, The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier. Not too shabby.
No other app showed that kind of user
growth in the week that ended on March 28th,
according to Apptopia's data. Netflix
app downloads actually declined by 1%,
though Netflix's market dominance
means that growth will naturally
be slower. Netflix has over 200 million
subscribers worldwide, according to CNBC.
There are also positive numbers for people
streaming Zack Snyder's Justice League on
other devices, too. SambaTV, another third-party
data analytics app, reports that 2.2 million U.S.
households and 954,000 U.K. households watched
the film in its first week of release on,
"Opted-in SmartTVs with 'automatic
content recognition' technology."
The limited nature of that data set means
the actual number is likely much higher.
The viewer numbers for Zack Snyder's Justice
League are below Wonder Woman 1984's first-week
viewer estimate — over 3 million American
households watched Patty Jenkins' Wonder
Woman sequel on HBO Max in the week between
Christmas and New Year's. Fortunately,
Wonder Woman 1984 is more of a sibling competitor.
The actual threat came from The Falcon and the
Winter Soldier, which Zack Snyder's Justice
League appears to have handily overcome.
According to Deadline, SambaTV found
1.8 million households watched at
least five of the movie’s 242 minutes in
the movie's first three days of release,
while 1.7 million households watched the Marvel
limited series in the same time frame. Justice
League's victory is also pretty impressive
in light of the fact that the Avengers:
Endgame sequel series is Disney+'s biggest
series premiere yet, according to Variety,
posting higher first weekend numbers
than WandaVision and The Mandalorian.
Of course, the viewer numbers themselves aren't
the most important metric for streaming services.
The most important things are sign-ups and
subscriber retention. It's a little too
early to say if the $70 million Warner Bros.
put up to finish Zack Snyder's Justice League
was money well spent, in terms of driving and
retaining HBO Max subscriptions. We may never
know the film's profit and loss. Even thinking
about how to calculate that is complicated,
and maybe it doesn't matter. If
the Snyder Cut's true purpose
was to plant positive feelings about HBO
Max in the minds of millions of people,
AT&T — the parent company of the WarnerMedia
conglomerate — is probably happy with the result.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about Zack
Snyder’s Justice League are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.